quatre amis sylvie tellier alors s'il
était gelée sur les réseaux sociaux les
gens l'ont fracassé la peau ben ça c'est
pas gentil non alors on va voir ce ciel
était omniprésente lors de la cérémonie
c'est un duo en pratiquement on l'a
également vu faire une belle boulette
voilà on a des images on va vous montrer
voici le visait le vis ma vie de sylvie
tellier qui était belle elle est
sympathique dans la vie civile moi je
vois c'est après ce mouvement
présentatrice télé quand vous n'avez
trouvé comment vous dites la vérité
non mais c'est un métier c'est pas si on
les présentateurs télé qu'il en est
agent immobilier peut pas que les deux
exceptions elle s'en est bien tiré mais
je veux dire j'aimais bien quand c'était
jean pierre jean pierre tout seul
présente trop présentes on regarde
regarde jean pierre
[Musique]
ce soir dans vis ma vie sylvie 40 ans
éleveuse de miss en région parisienne a
décidé d'échanger sa vie avec celle
d'une animatrice le temps d'une soirée
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes impatients de
savoir qui décrochera ce soir la
couronne de distance alors découvrons
plus attendre notre miss régionales dans
leurs plus beaux costumes revisitée par
des créateurs en région alors miss
aquitaine comment ça s'est passé
on s'est vraiment amusé sur scène
j'espère que ces ressentis dans la salle
en tout cas nous c'est ce qu'on a
ressenti
vous étiez superbe et on est ravi
je me sens tout essoufflé et vous avez
perdu votre écharpe mais où elle joue
alors les filles ça vous fait quoi de
revenir sur scène comme ça alors comment
allez vous étonner alors que la ville a
mis 4 jean michel berger micachu c'est
trop formaté les trolls promoteurs elle
a trop envie de passer à la lumière de
se montrer voilà je trouve quoi alors
camilla meilleur ami un vrai bon moi
j'aime bien parce que si c'était si tf1
ils se sont dit jean pierre foucault il
va peut-être s'en aller on veut une
remplir un remplaçant ou une remplaçante
c'est pas sylvie tellier je vais tout de
suite faut arrêter ces marques et aux
vernets en grand devant allah dit
aquitaine à la bafouille et bien sûr que
ça arrive je dis pas que ça arrive et
puis moi sylvie tellier ce côté hors jeu
excusez moi mais c'est le genre de
personne je la connais pas elle m'a rien
fait je n'ai jamais rencontré ps quand
je vois sa tête j'ai envie de changer de
chaîne
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce qui se passe vous êtes pareils
petit peu d'accord saad a même fait un
petit peu peur elle et par elle se
change directement et là j'ai eu du mal
justement à regarder parce que j'adore
miss france et les ja trouvé vraiment
trop présente
on va voir qui a mis une bonne note
gerald ciolek all à 2 je trouve que
c'est la patronne c'est la taulière je
trouve que justement elle a su
moderniser complètement l'élection miss
france
aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup plus des
miss france qu'avant reste que voilà
temps ci avec jodie avant d'en parler
autant non mais on n'a pas deux mais je
trouve que ça a été ça a été un relais
était très positif pour l'élection miss
france jugeant bienvenu alors on en
parle et on pas entendu je donne est en
train de lire la bd parce que c'est
alors elle est à la fois nul et
arrogante et là me l'ont pas possible
elle veut prendre la place de foucault
elle est en grande difficulté dans ces
élections miss france qu'elle a fait
n'importe quoi tout était biteau de
bidonner je voulais je vous dirai
pourquoi annoncer une prestation
calamiteuse des bourdes des erreurs je
n'ai jamais vu ça je parle en tant que
femme aimée senti comme ça sur sylvie
vrai mais tu mérites pas vous l'aimez
bien suivi mais bien sûr mais comment ce
dur mais pourquoi je vais cesser
virginie calmels qui avait foutu bah oui
la peau l'ex patronne en débat n'a pas
réussi à juppé en tous les cas on sait
avons déjà non un déjeuner 11 également
reste tout à l'heure pour me dire qu'on
renvoie quand est-ce qu'on déjeune et on
aime bien sylvie voilà je te laisse à la
semaine dernière au patrimoine dans la
salle et la nièce pure méchanceté en
exemple dans ce cas d'amiens geneviève
les ardeurs partager ce qu'ils me dire
quand même c'est que c'est quand même un
direct ouais c'est quand même c'est
quand même à plus 7 millions j'aurais
bien savoir qui peut faire un vrai
assure sa l'émotion on peut se tromper à
lèvres justement n'est pas prometteur
puisque sinon elle se trompe pas c'est
très compliqué à faire et en plus elle
ne veut pas prendre du tout la pied la
place de jean-pierre foucault c'est pas
elle qui va prendre la place
c'est peut-être un autre protégé qui
venait d'ici
quand il faut il faut parler non c'est
un beau duo après qu'on aime ou qu'on
aime pas mais on peut pas dire qu'elle
soit calamiteuse
alors moi aussi j'ai trouvé je trouve
qu'à se démerder virale